cette annonce sur Volkswagen qui
provoque beaucoup de réactions depuis le
début de la semaine a été faite par le
ministre fédéral de l'innovation des
Sciences et de l'Industrie
François-Philippe champagne qu'on
retrouve à Trois-Rivières ce soir
bonsoir Monsieur champagne bonsoir
Monsieur Philippe merci de m'avoir
invité grosse semaine pour vous en tout
cas avec cette usine en Ontario vous
êtes allé en Nouvelle-Écosse aussi
annoncé un investissement pour Michelin
il y avait des contributions
l'accroissement de la capacité d'un
fabricant de vaccins à kirklun ce qui
restait de l'argent à dépenser au
gouvernement fédéral en fin d'exercice
fiscale
non c'est pas tellement ça d'abord moi
je dis on parle d'investissement parce
que d'abord faut dire vous avez
mentionné Volkswagen goûter il me suffit
juste un coup de circuit pour le Canada
c'est un vote de confiance important
vous en conviendrez alors qu'on se
demandait ce que le Canada peut vraiment
être compétitif est-ce que le canal peut
vraiment tirer des investisseurs
importants là vous avez votre gueule le
plus grand manufacture automobile qui
s'installe ça va de confiance pour le
Canada pour l'industrie automobile mais
aussi les travailleurs les travailleurs
parce que ça c'était important je
pourrais en parler avec vous lorsque
fait pourquoi ils ont choisi parce que
vous savez d'abord fallait intéresser
vos Volkswagen à venir en Amérique du
Nord deuxièmement il regardait les deux
côtés de la frontière et finalement ils
ont choisi et pourquoi du côté de
saint-ambus et pourquoi saint-amu c'est
pas le territoire américain aux
États-Unis où il y a quand même de
fortes subventions pour le secteur
électrique il y a cinq choses qui nous
distinguent d'abord c'est le talent et
je pense les gens l'oublient mais le
Canada demeure
j'allais dire
ça veut dire des gens dans l'écosystème
parce que l'idée avec Monsieur fait du
Gabin mes collègues long terme c'est
d'amener l'ensemble de la chaîne mais il
y a une chose qu'on a dit de façon très
claire monsieur Fillon dans le dernier
économique d'automne que nous avions
l'intention de de
maintenir cette équivalence là au niveau
de l'attractivité du Canada mais la
grande différence c'est que nous on
serait sélectif parce qu'on peut pas se
permettre les Américains peuvent offrir
par contre effectivement il faut faire
partie de l'équation mais je vous dirai
pourquoi
c'est un Ontario cette usine là va et
pas au Québec dites-moi pourquoi c'est
une série de facteurs vous savez c'est
grand donneur d'ordre là ils regardent
plusieurs choses les deux provinces
étaient considérés au départ il y a des
questions de terre disponibilités il y a
l'énergie il y a la logistique vous
savez JM est venu du côté du Québec
alors que ils ont des unes en Ontario
cette fois-là va Volkswagen va du côté
de long terme mais ce qui est important
à me suivre les gens le comprennent
j'espère
pour renforcer l'écosystème c'est un peu
comme on a fait un aérospatiale où on a
eu prête à Whitney on a eu bel
hélicoptère ensuite de ça du bombardier
Airbus l'important c'est de consolider
l'écosystème parce que vous savez en
vous et moi en Beck en cours jewing-gum
symptômes quand on regarde ça sur les
chaînes mondiales c'est comme des villes
voisines parce que pour eux honnêtement
quand il regardait la planète l'idée de
venir des gens au Canada c'est ce qu'on
a gagné et puis moi ce que j'espère
c'est que les gens soient fiers parce
que ça prouve qu'on est capable de
gagner qu'on peut être ambitieux est-ce
que le Québec manque d'énergie quand
monsieur fait Dubin dit on n'a pas les
moyens d'amener ça jusqu'à Montréal
comme Volkswagen ne demandait
est-ce que ça a pesait dans la balance
pour ne pas finalement s'installer au
Québec mais en Ontario je pense qu'il
faut être sélectif et vous savez la
question est-ce que ça joue est-ce que
ça pèse c'est sûr que moi je vous
parlais l'idée qu'on est en train de
décarboner les chaînes
d'approvisionnement c'est sûr que
l'énergie renouvelable joue beaucoup
mais je répondais à votre question dans
le sens où ce qu'il faut comprendre
c'est que c'est grand donneur de là
commence par la fin il décède une date
de production puis partent de 100 ans
qui peut accommoder ma date de
production c'est pas typique c'est pas
comme les autres industries qu'on a
connu à travers le pays tu sais d'abord
moi je dis le Québec rentre par la
grande porte dans le secteur automobile
parce que ce qu'on fait chez nous au
cœur du Québec avec bécancourt
Trois-Rivières c'est ce qu'on appelle la
note de la cata ça c'est environ 60 % de
la valeur de la batterie puis la
batterie c'est 40 % de valeur du
véhicule alors contrairement à ce qu'on
a fait dans le passé dans d'autres
industries de l'ont sincère dans dans le
cœur de la chaîne d'approvisionnement
que le Québec puisse avoir des
investissements au centre du Québec qui
dépendent dans le fond de la grosse
usine et des milliards investiaires
symptômes en Ontario pas vraiment parce
que si vous parliez puis je vous invite
à l'inviter le CO de JM vous dirait que
l'usine de baie-cancourt est la plus
stratégique de toutes les usines de DJM
en Amérique du Nord pourquoi parce que
toutes les unes de djerm en Amérique du
Nord vont dépendre de ce qu'on produit à
becancourt alors ce que je vous dis la
stratégie qu'on a essayé de faire comme
j'ai fait avec moderna c'est de
s'insérer dans des chaînes
d'approvisionnement de façon stratégique
là vous avez beckencourt au cœur de
toutes les usines de JM volkswagen vient
et je vous dirais depuis qu'on a annoncé
parce que vous savez ça c'était sur le
fil de presse mondiale ben écoutez mon
téléphone est rouge pas parce que là
évidemment si c'est bon pour Volkswagen
tout le monde veut venir et là
évidemment vous l'avez dit il faut être
sélectif on peut pas tout faire on est
le Canada mais c'est sûr que là on a
envoyé un signal fort à travers le monde
qu'on ait une juridiction de choix on
les chaînes d'approvisionnement verte à
travers le monde on parle d'un projet de
1400 terrains de football quand on parle
de la grosseur 900 MW en électricité si
le Québec n'y arrive pas sur le plan
énergétique comme nous le disait
monsieur fitzguiben pour ce projet-là où
est-ce que l'Ontario va trouver son
énergie pour ce méga projet il y a eu
des études qui ont été faites là-dessus
mais je dirais pas exactement je fais
pas la même analyse le Québec
parce que vous dites que des études mais
je sais pas d'où on va venir l'énergie
de l'Ontario comment l'Ontario peut
accueillir cette usine là d'abord jouer
direct il y a d'autres projets qui s'en
viennent écouter l'enjeu là c'est
d'accommoder tous ces projets là c'est
ça l'enjeu qu'on a parce qu'il y en a
plusieurs qui vont arriver soit du côté
du Québec l'Ontario ça c'est la bonne
nouvelle parce que l'idée c'est de créer
l'ensemble écosystème c'est pas juste le
cellulier c'est l'ensemble des
écosystèmes donc ça c'est une bonne
nouvelle ça c'est un catalyse parce que
ce qu'on fait d'un côté ça va aider
l'autre il y a pas de compétition le
Québec est l'Ontario l'idée c'est
d'abord de les amener en Amérique du
Nord puis les avions de la France
naturel ça va venir du nucléaire de
l'énergie l'énergie l'étude qu'ils ont
fait Volkswagen là-dessus sont assurés
qu'il y avait un bloc d'énergie mais
encore là je pense que vous avez
identifié l'enjeu c'est pas la
disponibilité c'est la disponibilité à
court terme j'ai écouté le Miss France
Gabin qui était très clair c'est que
pour Volkswagen pour qu'on se comprenne
très bien avec les auditeurs les
auditrices eux ils commencent avec une
date de production ils disent qui peut
accommoder cette date-là au niveau des
terrains au niveau de la faisabilité au
niveau par exemple d'avoir les talents
autour au niveau d'avoir le bloc
d'énergie alors je pense c'est ça qui se
disait récemment c'est que le Québec va
être capable mais est-ce qu'on était
capable à ce moment d'accommoder
l'échéancier qui avait été soumis au
Québec
écoutez je vais laisser ça pour un livre
un jour parce que vous savez moi je
parle un peu à tout le monde et je vais
pas tout vous dire aujourd'hui je vais
regarder pour le livre mais il y a une
chose qui est certain ça va prendre du
temps avant d'avoir
est-ce que il y a eu des négociations
avec le Québec est-ce qu'on était
vraiment rendu à un choix ou ça aurait
pu aller au Québec ça a commencé d'abord
monsieur Fillon la grande chose c'était
d'abord de les intéresser les chaînes
d'approvisionnement se régénalise donc
là il y avait une idée de venir en
Amérique du Nord mais le coût de circuit
c'était de les amener au nord parce que
la vraie compétition monsieur Fillion je
sais je comprends votre question mais
c'est vraiment les États du Sud versus
le Canada et je peux vous dire quand je
suis allé quand ils m'ont invité à aller
présenter au siège social devant les 500
leaders de Volkswagen des 12 marques
pendant 30 minutes ils m'ont dit le
plancher est à vous faites-nous le corps
pourquoi le Canada et là je vous dirais
ensuite de son est passé du pourquoi le
Canada au comment et quand et c'est là
qu'ensuite de ça moi je suis toujours
transparent avec soit mes horaires de
l'Ontario du Québec quand on regarde les
deux tout le monde est au courant puis
éventuellement compte tenu des des
demandes et de l'échéancier ben ça c'est
dirigé du côté de l'Ontario mais la
bonne nouvelle c'est qu'il y en a encore
des choses à venir puis on travaille
main dans la main avec le ministrement
pour les faire atterrir ici au Québec
comme je le fais du côté de l'Ontario et
on attend votre biographie qui viendra
un de ces jours merci Monsieur champagne
merci Monsieur Fillon toujours un
plaisir pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]